hello everyone this is the second
lecture on the topic of on symmetric
bending of beams so in this lecture we
are going to discuss some of the
important steps that we need to follow
while solving various kinds of problems
on this topic so what do we even mean by
solving problems well in order to
understand that we need to quickly refer
to the first lecture that we had on the
previous day so if we go back to the to
the development of the mathematical
framework that we were discussing the
other day we will see that what we ended
up deriving was basically first the
formula for the orientation of the
neutral axis and then another formula
for the bending stresses the Sigma xx so
let's take a quick look at that so here
we have the tan beta so let me just
highlight this this is the tan beta
where beta is the angle that the neutral
axis makes with the y axis of the cross
section so in order to understand that
we'll quickly refer to the diagram that
we had drawn the other day so this was
our fairly complicated diagram and you
can see that we have the y axis here and
this yellow colored dashed line which
was superimposed by the purple colored Z
dash axis that was our neutral axis and
you see that the angle that this neutral
axis makes with the y axis that is
denoted by this beta so the formula that
we had derived tan beta gives us the
orientation
of the neutral axis you please note that
this formula includes the geometrical
parameters I why I why Zed I said as
well as the values of the moments my and
MZ both in the numerator as well in as
well as in the denominator next we had
gone on to develop the formula for the
bending stress the Sigma xx and let me
just highlight that for you again so
this was our fairly big formula for the
Sigma xx now let us remind ourselves
very importantly that both these
formulas the in fact the entire
mathematical framework that we had
developed the earlier daim it was solely
pertaining to the case of the pure
bending of beams however we did not
restrict ourselves to any particular
cross section it was meant for any
general cross section the other
important thing was that the y axis and
the z axis that we were considering
where centroidal axis that is they both
passed through the centroid of the cross
section okay so when we so today when we
want to discuss problems or the key
steps the primary steps that we should
be following while solving our problems
what we basically mean is that we want a
a prescription or a recipe to follow in
order to be able to find out the value
of Sigma xx at any given location within
the cross section and given certain
values of the bending moments so in
terms of the formula what we want to
find out is the value of Sigma xx is the
value of the Sigma xx at any particular
Y & Z that is at any particular point
within the cross section given certain
value of the bending moment that is
certain combination of this value
of my and this value of MZ please note
that for a given cross section the
values of I Y Z and I Z will be a
constant again if we look back at the
tan beta formula we'll see that it also
contains the MZ my and of course the iy
I've I said now when we want to develop
the steps or you want when you want to
note down the steps first and foremost
think that we have to do is to find out
the values of these geometrical
parameters that is iy I Y Z I said as
far as we are concerned about finding
the tan beta similarly for the Sigma xx
also our first job is to find out the
value of this iy said I said and I why
because in any given problem or in any
problem the MZ and the my values would
be given because there is the externally
applied load furthermore we would be
interested at a particular location so
the Y act the Y and the Z values would
also be known to us so in today's
lecture what we'll be basically doing is
to talk how to find out these second
moments of area now this seems like a
very easy thing to do especially if we
remember what we had already done or
covered in our undergraduate classes but
please note that we are no longer
considering very nice symmetrical cross
sections so we would be interested in in
real-world engineering cross sections
which could be very nicely W symmetric
like a rectangular cross section or a
square cross section or even a perfectly
symmetric cross section like a circular
one but it is also very much possible
that the cross section may may not have
any symmetry at all so towards that and
what we would like to do is to first
start off very quickly with the
rectangular cross section only but we'll
see that some key point which we'll have
to note so so the first step
so the first step is basically that we
need to find out the centroid of the
cross section
find the centroid of the cross-section
why is the why is this the first step
because you note that the entire
mathematical framework that we had
developed in the previous class referred
to y&z axis which pass through the
centroid so if we take a quick look at
the previous diagram so here both the y
axis and the z axis they passed through
this centroid so this was the centroid
of the cross section so if we have to
use the formulas that we had derived in
the previous lecture we need to consider
centroidal axis okay
the next thing that we need to find out
we need to find out the second moments
of area now both these steps could be a
little bit time-consuming but things can
be made fairly simple or simpler if we
proceed in a very nice step-by-step
fashion so towards that end what we'll
do is to first consider the simplest of
cross-sections which is the rectangular
cross-section of course the circular
cross-section will be sick much simpler
than that but will not consider that so
going ahead will first consider it a
rectangular cross-section okay
now the first step as we had mentioned
in the previous page was to find out the
centroid and we all know that the
centroid would be lying at well at a
distance which is halfway between the
the two parallel vertical edges as well
as the two parallel horizontal edges so
the centroid would be somewhere here now
this kind of a discussion is all right
as long as we are doing a qualitative
discussion but while solving problems we
need to have a proper recipe in order to
obtain nice quantitative values so what
do we do well the first step that we do
is to is to imagine that our origin is
at the left corner here so we imagine
that our origin is here because right
now we have not even set up our
coordinate axis that we would actually
need to use to solve our problem to us
finding out the orientation of the
neutral axis and towards finding out the
bending stresses because again I remind
you that we have to set up our
coordinate axis passing through the
centroid so we need to first look at the
centroid so towards that end the
centroid would be located in reference
to this point it is very much possible
to to have the starting origin here here
here or anywhere else but to keep things
simple and systematic for the purpose
for discussion today we'll consider the
origin to be placed here okay so if the
if this width is
it's W and well let me use this as the
breath so so I'll call this as B instead
of W I'll call this the breath and this
as the height H denotes the height so we
know that the center would be located
with reference to this origin at B by 2
and H by 2 now the moment we recognize
that the centroid is located here what
we'll do is we'll set up our coordinate
axis so we'll set up a pair of
centroidal axis in this fashion so this
will be our y-axis and said axis now we
all know that in this particular case
the value of isay would be 1 by 12 be H
cube I Y would be 1 by 12 B cube H and
I've I said will be equal to 0
so this was a fairly easy example we all
know about this but to go ahead we would
need a recipe to use these simple ideas
in more complicated situations so the
first step towards that would be to
realize that if we have a rectangular
cross-section but where the y axis and
the z axis are not passing through the
centroid then what are the values of AI
z iy and I why's it so what I'm saying
is that if we have a rectangular cross
section like this
and we have our z axis and y axis in
this fashion then what would be the
values of I said iy and I've I said now
one may wonder that if our entire
mathematical framework is developed for
the case where we are only bothered
about centroidal axis why are we even
considering a pair of center of a pair
of axis coordinate axis like Y y and z
which are not even lying within the
cross section so the motivation for this
particular discussion is that some
real-world engineering cross sections
beams beam cross sections would be
composed of of a composite of such
rectangles so we'll discuss that that in
the next page but for now we'll just
quickly take a look at what happens to
the values of AI z + iy for this
particular setup so we have the same
kind of breadth and height as before but
very importantly we recognize that our
centroid is still here and the distance
of of a pair of axis of a pair of
centroidal axis so let's say if we have
a pair of centroidal axis like this so
let's say this is y - and said - so
these are centroidal axis so what is the
distance between Z - and said and what
is the distance between y dash and y so
let's denote this by so this distance
by DZ and this particular distance
between the y dash and the y axis by dy
so in this situation our eysie will be
basically formed from a contribution by
considering the centroidal axis as well
as the actual axis that has been given
to us please note that the Z that the
eysie that we are considering is with
reference to the given z axis which is
the red coloured axis here so first of
all refer to the Z dash axis what we
have is 1 by 12 bhq just as before but
this is only in reference to the Z dash
axis that is the centroidal axis which
is not the given axis so in order to
find out the correct value of isay refer
to the given axis what we need to do is
to use the parallel axis theorem so that
this will be plus the area of the
rectangle or the area of the cross
section which is BH times the distance
between the Z dash and the z axis
squared so this will be DZ square in a
similar fashion if we talk about iy it
will be 1 by 12 B cube H plus the area
of the cross section which is BH again
and the distance between the y dash and
the y axis which is dy square of that
finally for our iy said we have first of
all the 0 contribution by referring to
the centroidal axis y dash and Z dash
but refer to the y and z axis we have
the area of the cross section
times the distance between the y dash
and the y axis which is dy times the
distance between the Z dash axis and the
z axis which is DZ so overall this is
what we have to do when referring to
this kind of a setup so let us take a
look at where this kind of an
application would be useful so the first
cross section that we are going to
consider would be something which is
fairly common in real-world engineering
practice and it is something like this
okay so this is this looks like an L and
this is the this is the shape of the
cross-section and you understand that
the beam is into the plane of the into
the plane of this screen here so how can
we apply the concepts that we had
developed in reference to the to the
rectangular cross-section earlier
so the idea sphere is quite simple what
we need to do first of all is to think
of this rather unsymmetrical cross
section this unsymmetrical L cross
section as being composed of two
rectangles so what we do is we take an
imaginary cut through here and then we
say that this L section is composed of
this rectangle and this rectangle
all right so how does this step help us
well you see if we refer back to the
important steps that we need to follow
while solving the problems of
unsymmetrical bending our first job is
to find out the centroid and the second
one is to find out the second moments of
area now coming back to the two this
l-shaped cross section to find out the
the centroid of this cross section
starting from those integration formula
that we had discussed at the beginning
of the previous lecture is not so easy
what is easy however is to is to
consider how you may find out the
centroid by considering it to be
composed of these two rectangles so what
we can do is in order to find out the
the the two coordinate points which
would be representing the centroid we
first start by imagining that our
starting origin is here it is absolutely
possible to take our starting origin at
any other point but just to keep the
discussion simple and systematic wheels
will start our we'll start with our
origin here so the location of the
centroid will be referred to this
particular origin now refer to this
particular origin the the centroid of
the red colored rectangle if we
recognize that this length is let's say
W
and this length is H then the centroid
of the red colored rectangle would be at
W by 2 and T by 2 where T is the
thickness here similarly we have the
same thickness for this particular leg
of the L cross section so both this move
these legs have thickness T so the
centroid of the red colored
cross-section would be at W by 2 and T
by 2 what about the blue colored cross
section well this will have the centroid
at H minus T by 2 and T by 2 well those
are for the individual centroids but
what about the composite centroid of the
entire cross section to find that out
what we need to do is to just note that
the Z coordinate of the of the entire
cross section would be calculated in
this fashion the area 1 times the z1
plus area 2 times z2 divided by a1 plus
a2 so what we are doing here is to
denote the area of the red colored
rectangle as a1 and the Z coordinate of
its centroid as z1 similarly we are
denoting a 2 to be the area of the blue
colored cross section of the blue
colored rectangle and z2 to be the Z
coordinate value of its centroid that is
the centroid of the blue colored
rectangle and of course a1 plus a2
represents the area of the entire
cross-section so let us remind also this
again that when we are writing these
values of Z 1 and Z 2 we are basically
referring to this starting origin here
so we are referring to this thing here
and you can note that we are thinking of
something of the z axis to be like this
and the y axis to be like this so
I think it will be better if we denote
this by Y - and z -
so that our z1 will be actually said one
bar and said two bar here in exactly the
same fashion we'll have the y coordinate
of the centroid as a 1 y 1 dash plus a 2
y 2 dash divided by a 1 plus a 2 where
just as before y 1 dash refers to the y
coordinate of the red colored cross
section and Y 2 dash refers to the
center the y coordinate of the blue
colored cross section the y coordinate
of the centroid of the blue colored
cross section now whatever we have done
here is follows from a fairly general
idea that whenever we have any cross
section composed of these sorts of
rectangles then we can then we can have
exactly the same kind of formula for
this Z see in the centroid and Y say for
the centroid by extending this not only
for a-1 a-2 but possibly also for a3 and
a4 if we have more such rectangular
cross-sections contributing towards the
composition of the entire cross section
but right now we are only concerned with
two rectangles making up the current
cross section okay so what we do going
forward so the moment we have the does
the values of Z Z NYC we can go ahead
and and identify the actual centroid of
the whole cross section
which will be lying somewhere here and
what we need to do next is to set up our
centroidal axis the real axis which
would be actually using to solve our
problem because again we remind
ourselves that in order to use the
mathematical framework to find out the
bending stresses and the orientation of
the neutral axis we cannot use the y
dash and the Z dash axis what we have to
use is a pair of axis passing through
the centroid okay so so this we denote
as y and z and whatever we do after this
has to be in reference to this y and z
axis now you please note that the z C
and the YC values that we had found out
is with reference to this starting
origin which was only a matter of
convenience to understand the geometry
but the moment we set up our y axis and
the z axis at the centroid you note that
refer to this new coordinate system the
coordinate values of the centroid are
nothing but zero and zero so this one so
this centroid has the coordinates zero
and zero referred to the y axis and the
z axis because that is where the origin
lies so now that we have identified the
centroid and set up our coordinate axis
at the centroid our first job in our
first step in solving problems is done
the next step is to find out the second
moments of area the second moments of
area of the whole l-shaped cross section
and in order to find out the values of
the second moments of area that is the I
said the I Y and the I Y Z will again
take the help of the idea that the
l-shaped cross section
is composed of this red colored
rectangle and the blue colored rectangle
and in order to go ahead what we will
use is directly the idea that we had
been discussing in the previous page so
we'll be discussing this idea so this is
our motivation so you see that when we
have a rectangle but we have to find out
the eyes in the Iowa and the Y said
refer to access which are not passing
through the centroid which is the y axis
and the z axis here this is the idea
that we have that we are going to use
you know to find out the I said the iy
and the iy set for our rectangular cross
section here so you see what we are
going to do so first of all you consider
this red colored cross section we
understand that the centroid of this red
colored cross section would be somewhere
here so if we were to draw centroidal
axis solely focusing on this red colored
cross section it would be having its
origin here it will be having its origin
here similarly if we considered the blue
colored cross section then its centroid
would be lying somewhere here so this is
the centroid here and the centroidal
axis for this particular cross section
would be having its origin here now the
pair of axis they are the pair of axes
that we are considering right now for
this particular cross section having its
origin here it will have a certain
distance from this z axis and have the
one the Y the Y counterpart will have
some distance from this y axis similarly
the y and the z axis which would be help
which will be having their origin here
would be having some finite distance
from this y-axis would be having some
distance from this z axis so we'll use
these ideas and the and the idea that we
discussed in the previous page to find
out the the second moments of area so
all that we need to do is is to first
consider the the individual second
moments of area of the red colored cross
section and the blue colored cross
section and then using the parallel axis
theorem we can find out the the actual
second moments of area of the whole
cross section so to give some concrete
form to the ideas let's let's actually
draw the the z axis here and let us draw
the z axis for the blue colored cross
section let us denote the distance
between this red horizontal axis here
and the the actual z axis here by the
distance D z1 so
this distance would be d z1 and this
distance correspondingly would be DZ 2
now writing the 2 within the superscript
is not the best of ideas because it can
itself look like a square so what we'll
do is we'll put this within brackets
here okay so we can go ahead and draw
similar distances between the the
corresponding y-axis but that'll only
clutter up the figure more and we only
need to understand what happens for the
eysie and we'll understand the whole
thing
so for the eysie for the entire
cross-section what we'll do is we will
first write down the contribution from
the from the red colored cross section
that is the the bottom one here so let's
say that the I said 1 denotes the the
second moment of area referred to the
z-axis of the red colored cross section
refer to its own red colored z-axis but
refer to the actual z-axis using the
parallel axis theorem we have to write
this as the area of the red colored
cross section times DZ 1 which is the
distance between the two z axis square
of that similarly considering the
contribution from the blue colored axis
what will help is eysie - so this is the
second moment of area of the blue
colored rectangle referred to its own
z-axis that is the blue horizontal axis
plus its area which we denote by a 2
multiplied by the distance between the
blue colored horizontal axis and the
purple z-axis which is just this
distance is a2 square of that
okay so proceeding in exactly the same
fashion we can write down the I Y and we
can also write down the I Y Z so let's
try to do that even though it may
clutter up the diagram a bit but let's
just go ahead with it okay so again
coming back to this red colored
cross-section this red colored rectangle
we have the y centroidal axis like this
and this distance
that'll be d-y superscript 1 in exactly
the same fashion
we'll have the centroidal axis referring
to the blue rectangle like this and the
distance between them between this
y-axis and the actual y axis that we
have to consider so this will be d y 2
so now we can go ahead and write down
the overall iy which will be like this
first of all we have I y1 referring to
the red colored rectangle the area a 1
times the distance between the 2 y
y-axis which is dy 1 superscript square
of that plus the iy
- plus a 2d y - superscript and square
of that so this is our iy and finally
for our I Y Z we note that refer to the
red colored vertical axis and the red
colored z axis horizontal axis so let me
repeat referring to this red color
triangle and the centroidal axis which
is this one these are the vertical
centroidal axis and the horizontal
centroidal axis referring to these the I
Y Z value is actually equal to zero
because as we can see from our previous
page when we had this kind of a setup
where this axis were actually passing
through the centroid of the rectangle
the I Y Z value was equal to zero so we
use this idea here to note that the
contribution to iy z
from this is actually equal to zero so
this is zero however we will have the
contribution from the a 1 x dy 1 DZ 1 in
a similar fashion we also understand
that I Y Z 2 would also be 0 but will
still have a contribution from a 2 dy 2
DZ 2 so in this fashion we can find out
the the values of AI z iy + iy Zed
so if you are wondering that that in the
in the previous lecture when we were
discussing the development of the
mathematical framework we really were
discussing a lot about the mechanics of
the whole situation but in today's
lecture we had we have not been
discussing at all about the mecha
mechanics rather we have been talking
solely about the geometry and in in real
practice when you have to deal with
problems dealing with various kinds of
cross-sections this is the first step
that you need to complete you first have
to deal with the geometry this is
absolutely necessary unless you have a
come complete control over these formula
you cannot proceed to the mechanics part
so once these steps are done it's fairly
easy to plug in the values of I said iy
+ iy said in the formula for tan beta
and the formula for the Sigma xx
provided you have also been given the
values of MZ and my so in an actual
problem solving scenario
this this is these two are very very
important steps now that we have gained
some sort of idea about how to tackle
problems involving this kind of a L
sheet cross section let's see how we can
extend these ideas to other types of
cross section we need not go through
these individual steps like this but
will will understand how these some
other kinds of important engineering
cross sections can similarly be composed
or thought of to be composed of such
rectangles once you have that idea in a
in a clean-cut form in our mind then
extending this ideas is fairly easy so
let's go to our next page and let us
consider some different cross sections
so the first cross section will consider
is like this
so this is a Z cross-section and just
like before we can imagine that we can
make some cut here and this Z cross
section can be thought of to be composed
of this rectangle this rectangle and
this rectangle and just like before we
can possibly start out by by imagining
that our Centro and that our origin is
here and we can find out the centroid of
this Z cross section by referring to
this starting origin and then we set up
our coordinate axis at the centroid and
then proceed from there in a similar
fashion we can have a cross section
which is like this
and so this is sometimes referred to as
a channel cross section and this cross
section can also be thought of to be
composed of rectangles by making these
two cuts so we considered a rectangle
like this
well dangle like this and a rectangle
like this so again we can start off by
imagining that our starting origin is
here and then we can find out the
centroid of this whole cross-section and
then after setting up our centroidal
axis we can proceed to find out the eyes
at the eye Y and the visor and finally
we can have a very common engineering
cross section widely used which is the
famous eye section
so
and again we can proceed by considering
this rectangle this rectangle and this
vertical rectangle please note that
unlike the other cross-sections this I
Section it does have some nice symmetry
associated with it but it can still be
subjected to some sort of unsymmetrical
bending if the if the bending moments
are applied on it in some kind of
arbitrary fashion and you know extending
our our discussion we can have another
section like the famous T section so
something like this
and just like before we can have this
rectangle and this rectangle
so in all of this it is very much
possible to to find out the values of I
said the iy and I've I said by referring
to these red coloured horizontal
rectangles and the blue colored vertical
rectangles it is of course possible to
have more complicated cross-sections but
these are some some fairly common some
really common real-world engineering
cross-sections so and you'll see that in
many textbooks these are the kind of
cross sections on which most of the
problems are based but you see as I'd
earlier discussed the eye section here
dissection here the T section here they
have some sort of symmetry this also has
some sort of symmetry but the L section
that we had discussed earlier this one
it doesn't have any symmetry especially
if you consider that W is not equal to H
here so if W is not equal to H it really
doesn't have any symmetry so if you can
get to grips with this L L section then
you can get some idea on how to deal
with unsymmetrical bending considering
all the general formulas now you know
because this is this is such an
important topic especially as it as it
pertains to real-world engineering
applications what I have done is in in
the github page of advanced mechanics of
solids I have already uploaded a Jupiter
notebook where and there is a mat mat
plot lab-based gy graphical user
interface which where you can play
around with these values of the W the h
and the T and you can also play around
with the applied bending moment to see
how the centroid changes with changes in
these lengths and how the values of I
said ìwhy and ice whyzard changes so
so what I have seen is that even when I
was a student going through these steps
is so very tedious at times that
students often get tired I used to get
tired while solving just one after
solving just one problem because this
involves so many calculations as you can
see that after solving this thing we
never I mean even if you're a little bit
lazy you'll never get any any intuitive
notion about the influence that the the
the that these lens that these
geometrical parameters can have these
are not like just some values that had
appeared in some problems these have
some real engineering some real
engineering significance the values of
this w the age and the t and my hope is
that by using that matplotlib based UI
in the github page and I'll provide the
link below you can develop a little bit
of an intuitive engineering feel about
the importance of these lens as it
pertains to the centroid the values of
the I said the iy and the I've I said
without going through all the pain of
these kinds of repetitive calculations
and my hope is also that someone may be
encouraged to to extend these ideas from
the L cross section to these various
kinds of cross section so if we can have
some matplotlib base Gy for these
various cross sections it will be have
it will be really nice to have some kind
of an intuitive feel about about some
very important engineering cross
sections so that's it for today so
if you have any doubts you can email me
I'll always respond to that and the plan
is that in in the next lecture we'll be
going on to the topic of shear Center
all right thank you very much